why did Playboy represent you on your
deal with Baywatch and stuff like that
like married with children with
everything because the only place the
only way people could get a hold of me
it was through Playboy I didn't have an
agent
and so why did I need an agent I didn't
think I was going to be an actress I
thought I was going home any minute I
was gonna I'll stay here as long as I'm
working and it just kept on going
see that makes me angry because Playboy
had no business representing you on your
contracts I know I had that given number
three selling Mattel toy like the Barbie
but I didn't get anything from those
kind of things it drives me insane I
mean why why didn't you Amazon Prime you
know now streams Baywatch I don't get
anything for that but we didn't have any
you know like there was no such thing as
streaming back then there's four
channels I mean I'm back in the you know
ABC NBC CBS FOX we didn't have
syndication and Baywatch was one of the
first indicated shows so it wasn't like
friends where they were making millions
an episode